fellow herbivores rise up
before
it's not just vegetarians huh vegetarian
you just describe vegetarians
yes no it's that it comes from a
Japanese term what social herbivore
social care
yeah it literally means herbivore what
like guys like social care means like uh
like guys who are not like they're very
docile and like not aggressive and
they're always like ladies first type of
thing and they're like never they never
Advance on girls and stuff like that and
they in Japan they're called herbivores
okay
I'm sorry I got the word from because I
[ __ ] love that term
I don't know why her before just sounds
so fun it's such a perfect time
yeah herbivore man yeah yeah before men
well I think that's because like Japan I
don't know like how how deep into like
vegetarian culture and vegan culture is
Japan in right now because I remember
when we moved here there wasn't really
much I think five years ago it's like
nothing right yeah vegan maybe
vegetarian I think it's vegetarian might
have been like one in a hundred
restaurants in Tokyo maybe but like yeah
I definitely think like now yeah since
the pandemic I think and even like a
little bit before that as well like I
did start to notice a lot of vegan
places as well as like vegan and
vegetarian like now there's it's not
infrequent to see menus that have like
the vegetarian symbol or like the vegan
symbol or something there's a few really
good vegan I go to actually quite a fair
amount of vegan places
I want a herbivore I'm not even like
vegan I don't care I just think that
like sometimes I just want food that
isn't gross feeling and vegan food is
normally like really clean there's a
vegan Ramen place I know uh I think in
Tokyo it's it's a change
or something something like that
something they do they do like uh cognac
yeah noodles it's actually really good I
hate yeah I hate konyaku I think it's
[ __ ] yeah it's disgusting yeah and I
don't stand for it yeah but the noodles
are pretty decent actually because I
accidentally ordered it and I I I was
like I hate konyaku and normally because
you get it in like some soups and you
get it in like a lot of hot pots yeah
yeah and it's it's like a potato but
[ __ ] yeah and I I normally just it's
like a gelatinous potato it's like slimy
potato it's so gross but the noodle is
actually really good because it was like
not slimy it was just kind of like a
little a little chewy but it's good it's
like the thin cognac yeah so if you want
Ramen it's a given it doesn't taste like
normal Ramen but Ramen that is very low
calorie and pretty healthy for you you
can get a vegan I was there I was
pleasantly surprised by it yeah because
I I went to it because one of my friends
uh is a vegetarian yeah I I think we're
talking about the same let me get the
place here we can recommend it yeah yeah
I went there because I was with one of
my vegetarian friends we couldn't find
any other like vegetarian place so we
just like oh let's just go to this like
the food place
um yeah and I went and I was like oh I
wonder because you know like a lot of
ramen is the polar opposite of vegan or
vegetarian right yeah yeah it's just
like it's very oily very you know it's
meat broth based and stuff like that so
I thought like it's gonna be this is
gonna be like the featheriest [ __ ]
Ramen ever with like no substance
whatsoever but it was it surprisingly
fills you up and it's and and again it
like it's Ramen without the gross
feeling it's it's Ramen without the food
coma yeah basically yeah so it's I I
think they did um there's like weird
broths as well I think the one I had was
spicy yusu spicy
spicy nice very refreshing very
refreshing I know there's vegan burger
places yeah that are apparently very
good never been like impossible bugs and
stuff yeah they're probably really good
um I know there's um a bunch of uh vegan
cafes so many of them right
um that are really good there's a few in
uh Shinjuku that I know and there are
like some just like traditional Japanese
Foods as well that are technically vegan
but I don't think until recently were
labeled as vegan yeah so I think it's
just like the fact that this is
obviously before the pandemic but like
when a lot more foreigners were coming
over and obviously with that there's a
higher population of vegans and
vegetarians outside of Japan because
it's not really a thing in Japan
um and you know I guess like a lot of
restaurants like oh there's a there's a
lot of these vegetarian and vegan people
that are coming to this country we
should probably cater towards them
especially since the Olympics are coming
up I wonder how they're doing after the
pandemic yeah all right sort of aligning
of the vegan places they normally always
have English menus yeah yeah that's true
which you know I don't need an English
menu all the time but it is just nice to
have sometimes you're just like ah [ __ ]
yeah I did I didn't want to read today
this is good she just I just think yeah
yeah yeah some really good options now
in Tokyo but I think the reason why a
lot of places get held back from being
vegan is eggs and stuff yes Eggs oh yeah
so much stuff with eggs that's true a
lot of stuff with eggs a lot of stuff
with uh fish and stuff like that fish
oils
like a lot of like uh you know like uh
animal bone broths and stuff like that's
very common yeah when's Yuzu going to be
more popularized around the world okay
it's too much
oh my God I like YouTube
let me I like you two let me I like you
let me preface okay because I was I was
a clown when I first oh my God okay
you're still a clown no no you are still
a clown I'm less of a clown no
I I took the hit off just a little part
of me as well I took one of the shoes
off and it only squeaks my when I
replaced her with a messy yeah it only
squeaks my take one of the steps now
does it does it mean if I picked like a
Twitter meme like a reply image that's
just someone putting on clown shoes yeah
it's gone getting ready for work just
the shoes
we give the [ __ ] clown shoes to each
other every week
but like when I first moved to Japan I'd
never had for some reason I'd never
heard of Yuzu before had you heard of
Uzi before well it's a very Japanese
foreign
what it looks like an orange more than
I'm like a hybrid between orange it's
like a lemon and an orange put together
for those you don't yeah yeah I mean I
mean I Look to that never like I I
thought I thought my brain went uh
usually must just mean lemon when you
take one look at a user you're just like
wow that's a big lemon yeah exactly
that's what I thought okay because at
least with limes limes different
completely different color but you know
there are like some Japanese like fruits
and vegetables that have the same name
but like what other fruit is yellow what
other fruit is yellow that's shaped like
that yeah exactly that's that's that
that was what I was thinking there's no
other fruit I know that's yellow in my
mind aside from lemon so I was like
great it's a lemon so I didn't know that
Yuzu and lemons were a completely
different thing yeah so I was and and
Sydney was just like how could you be so
[ __ ] dumb this is obviously a lemon
this isn't museums like what's what's
the difference what's so great about
using I don't get it but like now that
I've lived in Japan for two years
usually [ __ ] slaps man Yuzu is like
STS Citrus citrus fruit yeah a low
[Music]
Mexican Mexican Brothers rise up lime is
the best put it on everything lime has
always been the beta lemon like it's
it's been it's been like it's been like
the [ __ ] no it's been the most
no it's the exciting lemon oh my okay
okay we're not having this argument